est ce qu'on a déjà vu laurent
delahousse présenter son émission sur
france 2 avec les lunettes de maitre
gims 20h30 le dimanche
regardez je vous laisse on se retrouve
sur france 2 très rapidement
et puis vous pouvez continuer de faire
un seul film attendez allez on y va
ah bon ils font un seul film min et bien
ça c'est un bon gars bref c'est un bon
gars c'est vrai que c'est un bon gars
c'est que j'aime bien parce qu'il a pris
à des mecs qui sont jaloux lui il est
beau et intelligent j'attends donc pas
ça va bien ça va ça va nous parle ou ça
vous est ce qu'on a vu maître gims faire
des blagues très nul mais très drôle sur
snapshot
oui mais tu fais quoi j'adore mais tu
fais quoi gérard
[Rires]
c'est en tout ça mais nous attend si tu
vends les diffuse tous les soirs je te
mettrai juste après le singe
je te calcule après ce qu'on a vu sur un
site non merci
est-ce qu'on avait un youtuber et sa
maman cumuler les centaines de millions
de vues grâce à maître gims la reprise
alors oui on joue en ce moment là bien
sûr un génome est obligé dois tu connais
gérard a bon dos bon ça fait que nous à
main sapé comme jamais de cap et comme
j'aime un gamin tu contrôles année doha
précise qu'aucun des cocus côté mme
aminata qui passe avant minuit
e
si vous cher
bah c'est la mer si je vous aime
lyon
allez on en fait une dernière est ce
qu'on a vu catherine ceylac omap4 elle
était comme une folle sur sap et comme
j'habite mais non fournie
[Applaudissements]
faux elle était dedans mais elle voulait
rien lâcher quoi alors qu'il a déjà fêté
au café non
vous habitez tout cas si oui mes romans
ouais pourquoi mes romans propos propos
est parfaitement chez moi j'ai vu juste
et du pas parlé je peux pas